One of the things that
happens to Joseph is that,
well,
a lot of bad things happened to them
because he's the favorite of his father.
His brothers hate him.
And so the first they're
going to throw him in a pit.
I think they do throw him in a pit.
Then they sell them to be a slave.
Then he ends up in what
we go through the story.
He ends up some places where you probably
wouldn't want to go prison being one
of them,
but
it doesn't matter because even
when they put him in prison,
he's actually not in prison.
He just figures out how to make
the prison work way better.
And then he's in control of the prison.
And it's really,
it's an interesting,
I had this friend,
you know,
and he was very smart,
but very cynical,
and he wasn't employed very well and he
got a little older than he should have
given his level of
intelligence and employability.
And so he had to take jobs that weren't
very intellectually challenging.
You know,
and one of the things I tried to convince
him of was that even if he worked,
he wanted to work behind the parts
department in an automotive store cause he
liked cars but it was beneath him.
You know,
cause it was sort of a,
as far as he was concerned,
it was a,
he was too smart for a job like that,
which actually turned out not to be true.
He wasn't smart enough for a job
like that or he wasn't wise enough.
But you know,
I,
one of the things I tried to tell them
was that you're looking at the situation
wrong because even in a simple
job so called simple job,
like let's say dishwashing
in a restaurant,
which I did an awful lot of,
it's not that simple.
You're dealing with a lot of other people,
very fast staff changeover,
you're feeding people,
you're helping them have a celebration,
you're helping them take a break.
Like you can do it really well and then
the kitchen can operate properly and
then people can come
out to the restaurant.
It's not a bloody catastrophe.
Like you're,
even when you're doing
something that's a menial job,
so to speak,
like dishwashing,
there are ways of doing it really badly,
resentfully and horribly
and doing it really well.
And as soon as you do it really well,
it's not a menial job anymore.
It,
it immediately transformed.
No,
I mean,
you can be around people who won't let
that happen and you should go get another
job if that's the case.
But if you do it properly,
then it's not meaningful at all.
And that's also a good
way out of resentment.
You think,
well,
I've just got this,
you know,
two bit job.
It's like,
yeah,
what if he did it as well
as you possibly could?
You know what would happen?
Well,
the first thing that would happen
is you'd get a lot smarter,
that's for sure.
And that that's hardly a negative thing.